[Musik]
[Gelächter]
filme streamen finde ich toll und das
alles in hd qualität 3d 5.1 audio
vielleicht werde ich ja sogar geradezu
industrie
hallo etwa 60 prozent des weltweiten
datentransfers sind bewegte bilder und
die müssen gerechnet komponiert
übertragen gedownloadet baum gerodet
gecasht und wieder abgespielt werden
gigantische datenmengen jede menge
zurzeit im durchschnitt sorgen
online-videos jedes jahr für mehr als
300 millionen sind zwar mehr ein sommer
ganz spanien
[Musik]
fast ein drittel aller online videos
sind übrigens pornos circa 100 millionen
tonnen co2 für
wenn filme dann vielleicht datenqualität
router auch standard das spart energie
oder vielleicht mal wieder ins kino oder
oder einfach mal zusammen schauen
ob per internet oder auf dem rechner zu
hause digital zocken
für viele ein riesenspaß und ein
gigantischer stromfresser
doch dieses passivhaus in dresden zeigt
wie digitalisierung nachhaltig geht im
keller steht keine normale heizung hier
summen computer server aus dem
rechenzentrum der universität eine idee
von christof hetzer informatiker und
jens struckmeier physiker die beiden
freunde heizen mit der abwärme der
server
anfangs waren viele skeptisch die
handwerker könnten sich noch gar nicht
vorstellen dass man mit diesen servern
die ganzes haus beheizen kann genau aber
die heizung läuft ja schon jetzt seit
sieben jahre und überhaupt keine
probleme über einen speicher wird die
wärme abgegeben und von dort
bedarfsgerecht im haus verteilt die
produzierte wärme sinnvoll nutzen und
dabei noch strom sparen
eine kleine idee mit großer wirkung die
beiden gründen eine firma für green tech
heute hat das dresdner unternehmen cloud
enthielt mehr als 100 mitarbeiter
weltweit
geschäftsführer jens struckmeier leitet
den bereich forschung und entwicklung
optimiert die energieeffizienten server
täglich weiter er hat ausgetüftelt wie
man server abwärme nutzen kann
statt mit luft wird mit wasser gekühlt
das durch schläuche fließt das so
erhitzte wasser kann dann zum heizen
genutzt werden und das funktioniert
schon an 24 standorten allein in
deutschland
am beispiel von seiner grafikkarte
normale computer komponenten die
produzieren eben viel viel wärme und um
die wegzubekommen hat man sehr
aufwendige strukturen konstruiert zu
kühlrippen die da drauf geschafft werden
zum teil mit heatpipes und ventilatoren
die dann auch strom verbrauchen und
diese wärme dann erst mal in die luft
weg transportieren und im weiteren
verlauf des diesel warme luft dann
natürlich noch weg gekühlt werden
zum großen teil eben auch mit
klimaanlagen und wir vereinfachen das
ganze indem wir diesen riesen aufbaut
wegnehmen dann hat man sozusagen das
mainboard dass ich dann so aus da sieht
man schon welche komponenten die
wärmeprodukte
das ist im wesentlichen der chip und er
macht ihm ganz viel wärme unter können
wir so ein kühlkörper drauf machen diese
wärme dann in den kühlkörper bringen und
das ganze dann in ein kleines kunststoff
einbettet das hat mir hier mal gemacht
also hier ist der körper hier eingebaut
hier unten
das wird ihr drauf gesetzt und dann hat
man den geschlossenen kühlkreislauf dann
werden die ganzen komponenten jetzt
durch das wasser gekühlt das wasser wird
über diese kunst struktur geführt
man sieht schon wenn man die beiden
vergleichen und braucht weniger platz
weniger material und es ist viel viel
effizienter
der weltweite datentransfer wächst um
jährlich mehr als 25 prozent und damit
auch der stromverbrauch in den
rechenzentren schon jetzt verbrauchen
diese in deutschland etwa so viel strom
wie ganz berlin statt auf
einfamilienhäuser setzt cloud and eat
inzwischen auf größere unternehmen in
deren rechenzentren lassen sich
wesentlich größere mengen wärme nach
nutzen heißt wasserleitung gehen nach
oben in diesem schrank und werden dann
hier über die traverse übergeführt an
die heizungsanlage ein einzelner server
schrank beheizt die firmenräume in
frankfurt hat claudia enthielt die
technologie auf ein ganzes hochhaus
übertragen ein pilotprojekt noch sind
wassergekühlte server etwas teurer in
der anschaffung
doch die mehrkosten gleichen sich nach
wenigen monaten aus durch weniger
stromkosten und die zusätzliche
heizleistung
ich muss noch prüfen ob das platz
technisch passt dass wir ihn einfach bei
denen mit millimeter verschieben
nachhaltige digitalisierung steht in
deutschland noch nicht auf der
politischen agenda aber die nachfrage
steigt in einer montagehalle entstehen
mobile data center container
das sind besonders leistungsstarke
rechenzentren auf kleinstem raum
natürlich mit abwärmenutzung
ein solcher container könnte 300
einfamilienhäuser beheizen der aktuelle
trend neue technologien wie das funknetz
5g benötigen viele kleine rechenzentren
die näher am endkunden liegen das ist
eine chance für die nachhaltige
digitalisierung wenn öko strom und
abwärme optimal genutzt werden können
[Musik]